in the wake of the terrible events this
week America was left with many
unanswered questions as a society we
need answers and sometimes traditional
media fails us because they don't always
have them thankfully this week online we
saw the brave men and more men of
alternative media rush in to fill that
need with cold hard unsubstantiated
guesses a move that had the slow jealous
MSM crying their same old tune fake news
stories appeared on social media and the
hours after the mass shooting in Las
Vegas some people looking for
information read and then shared those
false articles without even realizing
that it wasn't true fake news in the
wake of the horrific tragedy in Las
Vegas platforms have struggled to keep a
lid on incorrect information incorrect
information please you can't spell
incorrect information without correct
information and the correct information
is that the mainstream media is wasting
our time conducting interviews verifying
sources and trying to assemble an
accurate picture of the suspects
background meanwhile brave online truth
tellers like Infowars and Gateway
pundits are getting to these answers
first they get their to their answers so
fast sometimes it feels like they didn't
even have time to think about them so
here at the opposition we have a way of
describing these courageous pushers of
pre verified truth the folks who aren't
afraid to just know the answers we need
they're spreading news that is not
verified but helping get theories out
and actively pursuing information about
who's hurting us that is it's a bit
wordy and mainstream let's let's tighten
that up let's call it not helping
actively hurting great now much better
so how are we in the alternative media
landscape not helping actively hurting
after this tragedy first we're offering
helpful pre verified truths about the
suspects political leanings like this
headline that appeared on White House
press credential holders gateway pundit
telling us that the shooter liked Rachel
Maddow moveon.org
and associated with something called the
anti Trump arming the anti Trump army
with their gluten-free grenades and
their artisanal artillery now the
mainstream media is saying the shooter's
motive remains elusive what am I
supposed to do with that if you're
reporting that there's no information it
doesn't count as reporting I don't go
around knocking on people's doors saying
hi I have nothing for you no I say hi I
have bad news about your dog also can I
use your bathroom Gateway pundit was
quick to post slightly less quick to
take it down when they realize they had
the wrong guy entirely but hey you can't
make an omelet without ruining someone's
life the hearts of the right place GP
that's what I call not helping actively
hurting now all our alt media brethren
Oh red Infowars went even further we've
got major Islamic connections leftist
connections the hotel owners being anti
feh
this guy being totally protected all of
this brings us back to the perfect Patsy
which is Steven paddock that's something
that could be totally step set up and
staged as well who knows when Steven
paddock actually died clearly this is
multiple shooters different angles yes
it makes sense the shooter was protected
by antifa
which doesn't matter because he wasn't
the shooter because he was killed before
the shooting started and also he was two
people
I see what you're throwing down I say
now Occam's razor says the simplest
answer is probably the correct one but
why are we listening to an old man's
razor I use Jordan's razor where the
correct answer is the one you arrive at
super fast without thinking which is
also how I shave now I know what you're
thinking Infowars haven't you done
enough the answer is no two words Illuma
notic oh yeah by the way there's the
pyramid which one of our crew members
pointed out this all happened under a
pyramid no symbolism there though oh but
he means there is symbolism the
Illuminati love pyramids do you have any
idea how hard it is for the Illuminati
to stage all their false flag attacks
near pyramids but basically restricts
them to Egypt Vegas and Nicolas Cage's
house good catch Infowars your scoop is
not helping actively hurting no you
might be saying look this is all sounds
great but how do we get these pre
verified facts beyond the red pill free
thinkers and crammed in the eyeballs of
the sleeping masses there's an app for
that
in the hours after the Las Vegas
Massacre fake news story started popping
up on Facebook Facebook responded by
blaming their algorithm quote were
working to fix the issue that allowed
this to happen in the first place
and deeply regret the confusion this
cause the company said blaming the
algorithm sounds pretty plausible to me
I think most things are Al Gore's fault
but it's not you understand you
understand it's not it's not just online
algorithms that are guiding people to
these pre verified truths our friends at
Fox News may have their hands tied by
corporate overlords but they're pointing
viewers to where the real info is go
online take a look some of the stuff
seems to be legit I'm reading a lot of
different things out there a theory that
he had been to the Philippines with her
we have not confirmed there's some
theories out there that there may have
been more than one gunman maybe this guy
I heard that song god bless america his
brother said he didn't believe in God or
didn't have a God or didn't have faith
in his life so maybe this is all
speculation but that possibly could be
the reason because he knows country
musicians or country music fans are
normally Pro God and go to church on
Sundays maybe he has a problem with that
or had a problem with that okay yeah you
can practically hear them thinking about
how good her idea is
[Applause]
[Music]